we're all generating lots of data in the
things that we do so it might be sort of
what you think of an explicitly data
generate when you I put something on
Facebook or you tweet something we have
an email or whatever but even activities
like driving or shopping now generate
quite a lot of data around there's a
notion of the data digital footprint for
example where that sort of captured and
the we sort of had this model we thought
a bit about how the world's kind of
developing this way and so we came up
this notion of something we call human
nature interaction so there's a field in
computer science called human-computer
interaction where people need studying
for a good 50 years now what's happening
now is it's less about interacting with
the Machine specifically as it is about
interacting with data data
the bounty of data was generated by you
and this data is used in the environment
by computational devices to do things on
your behalf or do things to you and
provide you with credit scoring or
things like this the model we sort of
drew for this was the idea that you've
got people and they generate data and
that data feeds into analytics
algorithms and those analytics
algorithms generate actions something
happens in the world as a result you get
a different credit score or you get your
mortgage or you don't get your mortgage
or whatever it might be your insurance
premium changes or something and those
actions change your behavior perhaps or
might involve more data inferences from
the data being put back into the data
set which are then used subsequently to
be politics and so on so you got the
option you can sleep at least in this
sort of behavior you have generates
things that change your behaviors on the
leak we have about this is the way that
this is evolving the way this is coming
about is missing various features that
are necessary and there were three in
particular that we defined legibility
agency and what we call them the Gauche
ability and so the notion with these was
the legibility is the ability to see and
understand what's going on or the
observation is that for a lot of people
it's very difficult understand all the
different sources of data that have been
collected about you and it's difficult
if you do understand them to see what
that data means and what the
implications are somebody having
collected that data might be agency then
is the capacity to act so if you do see
what's going on you do have someone
standing what's going on very often you
can only do very much about it and so
you can't go in and correct incorrect
data that's been closed about you and so
in the last mistake it's not what I
think or if somebody's drawn an
inference about you because they've
looked at your spending patterns and
they looked at your demographic and
they've looked at your tweets and they
decided that you are definitely a Tory
voter and you want to go and say no no
actually I'm not I'm an independent or
whatever it might be and people are
doing that sort of analysis to form
those kinds of inferences but quite
often it's difficult for you to go in
and change them and correct them if the
inference is incorrect and above these
inferencing algorithms well they're
quite good and they might be getting a
th box and accuracy that still these 15
20 % wrong data that's coming out of
that agency so the capacity to act
negotiability then is the idea that
actually these systems are dynamic so a
lot of the time when you sign up to the
services for example you check the box
you don't read terms condition
just say yeah I want to do it now give
me my gmail account or let me have
Facebook or something and you don't have
the ability to go back what you
understood a bit more about what's
happening and change that you tend to be
either you said yes all you said no very
often it's you've said yes and that the
it for all time increasing now some
company is getting better at giving you
a chance to pull back out again it tends
to means complete withdrawal I can take
all my google data out of Google I'm
going to leave but that's still quite a
binary kind of you either get it or you
don't get it you don't get so much
choice over what you can pick and choose
now you deal with that what I always
think of this is when you go on Amazon
and some point you bought some nice a
birthday present and then you get all
the recommendations getting the based
around that at least in under the new
suppose you've got the chance to say
don't use this but yeah that that's a
very simplistic part of data is it in
the Amazon Obama's can do this but it
may well be the case that some companies
on the web for example will share that
data with other companies and so even if
you do go and corrected at source that
correction doesn't get followed through
so all the other companies that have
them picked up that data set previously
to you going in correcting and so you
have this sort of bad data might use
kind of spreading around the place so so
we felt that a lot of the way that these
systems are currently constructed don't
pay attention to some of these these
features there may be other things that
are missing people then disagree about
how seriously things have with other
these things were certainly missing in
the problem so we were sort of thinking
about what could we do in terms of
building technology to try and create a
platform on which these things could be
addressed the observation then was that
well a lot of the way these systems work
is you take data from people and you
feed the data into some some
organization supposed to be Factory some
organizations machines right so the data
goes up into the cloud art was not my
subject as you can tell so data gets fed
into the cloud somewhere gets taken away
gets computed upon inference in the
drawing and so the whole thing holding
carries on I can be the problem with
this is what happens here
so once you've taken the data away from
the person you lose quite a lot about it
so you lose lots of metadata and context
about it you don't know where they came
from you don't know that the purchase
was for your needs anymore you just know
that the purchase
you've also created quite a technical
problem which is that you've now got
millions and millions of users where
you're kind of get data from all of them
and keep that and store that and manage
and manipulate that and that could be
quite expensive to do quite difficult to
do depending on the size the company
involved you know so a company like
Google and Facebook and Microsoft have
got the expertise to manage that and
they do they do that really well but for
companies that are sort of a bit smaller
than that or don't have that type of
technical background it's a very
difficult thing to deal with potentially
you've created a honeypot effective so
it's now the case that if you attack
that company is an attacker and you get
all the data you might get and millions
of people's later at the same time so
there's quite a value in being able to
get over that so there's are sort of an
attractiveness to make that attack
target and so this this sort of the the
observation is that this all sort of
starts from the idea that you taking
that away from people and you're taking
it somewhere else to do something with
it so what we've proposed in this
project called data box was that
wouldn't be good if we could provide
some technical means that would allow
people to keep their later
keep control of their data and sort of
manage access to that data so it's still
try and provide all the same facility in
terms of the analytics that might be
carried out but we try and do so in a
way that means that people the people
with a subject to use a technical
terminology the subjects are going to be
more able to see what's happening more
able to control what's happening and
more able to to make decisions about
what should happen it shouldn't happen
on a kind of a case-by-case basis rather
than having this sort of blanket yes I
accept all the terms this is fine there
are other sort of benefits as well as
legal benefits for example so there's
recent legislation from the European
Union's
that's coming in I think is due to come
in before brexit happens however that's
going to happen and that's going to
cause that causes for example data
protection to be even more stringent
than it already is and the fines in
place to be even more every way can they
already are so I'm not a legal expert
but as I understand it there was
legislation that states from Obama's
consumer protection consumer Privacy Act
I think although I believe that Trump I
the house or wishes to kick that out
again I don't know where that's going to
end up
I think that some of the similar views
held in Japan as well there's also
legislation Japan so this is not just a
European thing this there is only
concern about at all growing awareness
of this in a number of places in the
world so you've got this and as part of
that legislation is that there's a lot
in there about trying to design for
privacy trying not to collect data you
don't need to collect trying to make
sure that the data subject is aware of
the purpose for which the collection is
happening in the curves process is
happening what's going to come out of it
and so on so it's supposed to make it
all the more transparent so which is I
think in the end a good thing because
it's good that it would be good if
people could effectively trust what was
going on and understand what was
happening right so the idea was what can
we do technically to try and assist
people with that so notion with lace box
is the idea that we should explore the
possibility but instead of the data
flowing out and then being taken away
and stopped happening with it keep the
data locally and then if a company
wishes to my fake factory again not only
our factories anymore if a company
wishes to process this data what it
might do for example is it could send
some piece of conversation some app and
distribute that app to different peoples
data boxes can't Negril stick messages
that app could then compute across that
data work out some answer and then that
single answer gets sent back so we don't
need to know your shopping history we
just need to know whether you are a big
spender
meaning spender or the title that's
maybe that's all we care about right and
so I don't need to look at all that all
the information there I don't need that
sorry I don't need to need to look at
all the information I don't need to hold
all the information and I may not want
the copy of all the information because
that has now has certain obligations on
me as somebody holding data about you
that I have to I'm obligated to do
things for you now providing with
information about what I'm doing with it
store it appropriately keep it safe
secure all kind of stuff so it may you
haven't cut me better than me not to
have to do that and not to take on that
risk and that responsibility I'm looking
to your data on there and I'm thinking
if you looks a little bit like kind of
what we'll use mobile phones anyway then
we kind of put our details into a phone
and then say yes or no to acts doing
things of that data that sort of
permissions model this is not is kind of
similar yes I mean there are a lot of
problems without permissions model as
well
such as
understand what permissions really mean
or you again you don't have a chance to
choose about Commission's is like the
app demands these permissions you either
get them or you don't grant it or you
don't
although there are actually things you
can do with some of the phones so for
example Android phones I can't remember
the name of it but there's a library you
can install if you root your phone which
you can then have an app that provides
you with control over the permissions
being granted on the phone so
specifically you can get quite to each
other matters so it's really sitting
between the app on the actual dota yes I
mean built into standard Android now the
ability to control Commission's being
granted so you can you can take away the
missions from apps and they may not work
if you do that but you can take them
away and so you've got this coin
granular permission quite granular
control over it and the idea here is
sort of similar in the sense that we'd
like to be able to enable people that
exercise that sort of levels of control
there's a few things to say about this
but one is that I'm not saying that
everybody should have to exercise that
out of control all the time for all the
possible uses of all that data because
that would be completely infeasible and
such a pain but you should have the
ability to design you want and it may
well be that we can build tools that use
that ability to try and represent what
you want to do or keep you default
behaviors that make sense or at least
alert you when things have gone wrong
because of releases that have happened
but there's a sort of dozen need for
that kind of infrastructure to be made
available I think also it's not just
about stopping things happening so it's
not just the case that I want to stop
data going into the tab I might want to
it might be beneficial to me that if you
try and analyze my shopping habits you
don't do from the point you don't do it
from the point of view of a single shop
so on the example after this was when I
use living Cambridge ID to shop at Tesco
and Sainsbury's shop at Tescos to buy
the cleaning products the fruit and
vegetable quite cheap
I didn't think very much of the quality
of beacon fish counter the particular
test goes I went to and so I tend to get
that stuff from centers were thought of
as better but if you analyze those data
sets and Sainsbury's my team years of
filthy carnival while Tesco's you is a
first-edition
clean vegan and neither of these things
are true on neither one nor the other
they're on a mixture of those things and
so the idea here would be that you can
actually get benefits from this from
both the consumer and the data processor
point to you the data subject in the
data processor point
because you get a more you possibly get
access to a more complete picture of the
individual in question because you can
access more of their data because you're
accessing it for a specific purpose and
you're not just trying to collect as
much of it as you can in all these cases
is to give you more say in the matter so
that you're not you're not just the
product right you are actually an
individual in this and you have some
some say in what's what's being done
again I mean it's not it's not as simple
as saying that you just get everything
in it's all yours for example so one of
the other another challenge in this is
that the way I've presented this the way
we've talked about it and the way a lot
of people think about it is the idea
that you've got personal data and you
own your personal data is yours and it's
about you and actually when you stop and
think about it an awful lot of personal
data involves at least one other person
right so yeah if you look at I don't
know Internet of Things data sensing in
a home smart homes and things like this
that's everybody in the household is in
some sense representative now it's not
just you when I see we really do live
alone and never have any visitors which
maybe some people eat but but not in
most cases and even email emails usually
ought to sender and the receiver right
so there's at least two people that
might have a claim on the content of an
email and so this is the most of
ownerships a bit tricky and the notion
of personal data being solely owned by a
single individual is a bit tricky and so
then you end up with playing games like
well how do you how do you deal with
that when you might have two or three
people you want to say yes to something
and another person is representing the
data once they know to kind of what what
happens there so so yeah it's it's a
sort of challenging there are challenges
in this but it still seems like this
kind of construction where at least
we're letting the data subjects have
some say in these matters and have some
ability to act
I was thinking about that email thing we
usually to me it's the same person Sonia
received its means sending Manhattan
email to remind myself that producing
tonight I'm going to forget